Mind your decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar
You have a rectangle with dimensions of 2 and 1 and you have a second rectangle of the same dimensions
Now rotate the second rectangle and place it on top of the first rectangle in such a way that they're opposite corners overlap
The question is what is the area of the overlapping region between the two rectangles?
I thank Robin for the suggestion
Pause the video, if you'd like to give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
I will present one way to solve this problem
Consider the following right triangle and suppose the other leg has a length equal to x
Since the entire side of the rectangle has a length equal to 2 the remaining length on this
Rectangle will be equal to 2 minus X
by symmetry
The other rectangle will have exactly the same lengths the portion that's not
overlapping will be equal to x and the portion that is overlapping will have a length equal to 2 - x
We can then consider just this right triangle
By the Gougu Theorem x squared plus 1 squared is equal to the quantity [2 - x] squared
We're going to expand the binomial the x squared terms will then cancel out and we then have a linear equation
We can routinely solve this equation for x and we get that x is equal to 3 over 4
Let's substitute that into our diagram
We now want to consider the area of the overlapping region
Let's also consider the area of this right triangle, which is congruent to the other right triangle
We thus have the area of this overlapping region plus the area of two of these
triangles will be equal to the area of the original rectangle
The rectangle has an area equal to 2 times 1 which is equal to 2
two of these triangles will have an area equal to 3 over 4 multiplied by 1 which is equal to 3 over 4
We thus can solve for the area of the overlapping region and it will be equal to 2 minus 3 over 4
Which is equal to 5 over 4, and that's our answer
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube
As always thanks for watching and thanks for your support